Grand Theft Auto on lines latest update  smugglers run rolled out this week and  introduced a brand new Battle Royale  style mode called motor Wars similar to  player unknowns battlegrounds GTA online  new battle royale mode drops players  from the sky with parachutes forces  teams to scavenge for weapons of  vehicles and limits the size of the map  incrementally the mode does rely heavily  on the use of armed vehicles hence the  name motor wars but it definitely draws  significant inspiration from pub G have  you hopped back in to GTA online seeking  your own chicken dinner let us know in  the comments below and be sure to  subscribe for more GTA online updates  thanks for watching  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]